[Aplausos]
[Música]
si os preguntamos por Suecia Seguro
seguro y automáticamente muchos
pensaréis en el medio ambiente la lucha
contra el calentamiento global o incluso
el animalismo Al fin y al cabo hablamos
de un país en el que más del 10% de toda
la población es vegana o vegetariana Y
sí por supuesto también es el país de
greta zamber Así que es posible que
muchos penséis que Suecia es algo así
como el feudo de la lucha contra la
contaminación la industria y la
explotación de los recursos naturales el
país de las campañas por un mundo
distinto y mejor que deja tras el
materialismo y los excesos de la
humanidad para otros en cambio Suecia
seguramente sea el país promotor de la
socialdemocracia más radical las
campañas contra el desarrollo y
básicamente el rechazo a la vida
capitalista otros quizás pensaréis
también en la inmigración o en olas de
violencia
[Música]
sea como sea Suecia suele ser un país
que casi nunca deja indiferente a nadie
al menos a casi nadie pero más allá de
la política este país tiene también
otras facetas muy diferentes por ejemplo
qué pensaríais si os dijera que Suecia
es así mismo una de las grandes
potencias mineras de Europa Sí sí
potencia minera y Aunque eso no sea
Precisamente lo más ecofra del mundo y
tal cual como lo estáis escuchando Claro
que he dicho esto La pregunta es Pero
por qué demonios os ha dado en
visualpolitik por hablar de la minería
en Suecia realmente es algo tan
relevante pues queridos amigos amigas Lo
cierto es que sí tiene mucha pero que
mucha más importancia de lo que
podríamos pensar a simple vista fijaos
12 de enero de 2022 Suecia encuentra el
depósito más grande de Europa de tierras
raras que podría volverse más importante
que el petróleo y el gas tal cual como
lo estáis escuchando hablamos de un
enorme depósito de alrededor de un
millón de toneladas de óxidos de tierras
raras que se suman a otros descubiertos
en Finlandia Grecia y sí también en
España
[Música]
se conoce como tierras raras a 17
elementos minerales con propiedades
magnéticas luminiscentes y
electroquímicas únicas entre ellos se
encuentran el lantano o el neodimio que
se usan entre otras cosas para fabricar
coches o el itrio indispensable para
producir cosas tan dispares como los
semiconductores o algunos fármacos
y vale puede que ahora algunos esté
preguntando Pero entonces por qué hablar
concretamente de Suecia si hay depósitos
de estos mismos minerales en más países
pues no solo porque ese depósito de
tierras raras recién descubierto sea el
más grande de toda Europa sino también
por otros motivos No solo relacionados
con la minería así que sin hacer más
spoiler estáis preparados pues
arranquemos
[Música]
el Renacer del músculo minero
a ver la minería en Suecia no es
precisamente una actividad nueva
hablamos de un sector con mucha
tradición que se ha desarrollado desde
hace unos 6000 años de hecho una de sus
Minas más famosas la mina de falum que
ya no está en funcionamiento proporcionó
enormes cantidades de cobre durante casi
1000 años Ni más ni menos que desde el
siglo XX hasta 1992 de hecho durante
muchos siglos Suecia tuvo prácticamente
el monopolio del Cobre a nivel global
Así que hablar de Suecia y de la minería
pues no resulta nada sorprendente Los
lazos entre este país y este sector han
sido históricamente muy pero que muy
estrechos de hecho gracias a ello las
empresas suecas han desarrollado algunas
de las tecnologías extractivas más
avanzadas y limpias que existen por
ejemplo el hierro en Suecia apenas
genera entre una tercera y una cuarta
parte del impacto ambiental que tiene en
otros países menos desarrollados
[Música]
El caso es que actualmente Suecia tiene
12 importantes Minas en funcionamiento
especialmente en la mitad Norte del país
todas ellas están dedicadas a la
explotación de metales hablamos sobre
todo de hierro plomo zinc oro plata y
cobre de hecho Suecia ha sido el
principal proveedor de hierro en Europa
desde el siglo XVIII Y actualmente
produce atentos más del 90% de todo el
hierro que se produce en la Unión
Europea un tercio del plomo y del zinc y
una décima parte del Oro la plata y el
cobre
y ojo porque aunque esto pueda chocar
con la idea preconcebida que mucha gente
tiene de Suecia y también con el hecho
de que este sector sea en la actualidad
uno de los más señalados por los grupos
ecologistas así como por esa parte de la
izquierda que ha cambiado la revolución
del proletariado por el cambio climático
en este país se toman tan en serio la
minería que incluso van a cambiar de
sitio una ciudad entera para que uno de
sus grandes Minas pueda continuar
operando sí sí no estamos de broma
fijado una ciudad minera sueca que se
hunde en el suelo será reubicada
edificio por edificio hablamos
precisamente de kiruna el mismo lugar
donde se ha descubierto y el Grande
depósito de tierras raras que
mencionamos al comienzo de este vídeo
pero al margen de esta anécdota Lo
cierto es que con el cambio de modelo
productivo la transición energética y la
nueva movilidad impulsada por los
gobiernos de todo el mundo la minería
sueca podría estar a las puertas de
volver a experimentar toda una época
dorada y ojo que ni siquiera hablamos
solo de las tierras raras que os hemos
mencionado en los últimos años también
se están descubriendo grandes depósitos
de otros muchos recursos que resultan
absolutamente estratégicos para el
futuro especialmente si se quiere
cumplir con el objetivo de cero
emisiones de carbono en el año 2050 que
deis un ejemplo pues fijaos 25 de enero
de 2022 United lifum descubre dos nuevas
pegmatitas ricas en litio en el proyecto
Barbie en Suecia con perforación en
curso pues bien entre el depósito de
tierras raras descubierto en kiruna y
este de litio Suecia podría convertirse
con mucha diferencia en uno de los
países estratégicamente más importantes
de todo el viejo continente
[Música]
Y es que veréis para los que no estáis
muy puestos en el tema estas materias
primas las tierras raras y el litio
resultan imprescindibles para fabricar
cosas como los coches eléctricos los
aerogeneradores o gran parte de los
dispositivos electrónicos tanto es así
que muchos expertos los consideran más
importantes a largo plazo incluso que el
gas O el petróleo para producir una
generador de 3 megavatios requiere
335 toneladas de acero 4,7 de cobre
1.200 de hormigón tres de aluminio dos
de elementos de tierras raras así como
zinc lo que es realmente ilustrativo del
volumen de materias primas que
necesitamos para la transición ecológica
maros sexto bits vicepresidente de
relaciones interinstitucionales de la
comisión europea Pues bien Ahora sabemos
que Suecia es un país muy rico en
prácticamente todos estos recursos es el
principal productor europeo de hierro
que es la principal materia prima que se
utiliza para producir el acero un
importante productor de cobre zinc y
ahora podría convertirse también en un
gran productor de tierras raras y litio
o con otras palabras el subsuelo Soco
Pues hay casi todas las materias primas
que son indispensables para el
desarrollo tecnológico y la transición
energética pero ni siquiera se trata
solo de una cuestión meramente económica
sino también de seguridad no es que
Suecia pueda ser un productor más sino
que según datos de la propia comisión
europea actualmente en torno al 98% de
las tierras raras que se consumen en la
Unión Europea proceden de un único país
sabéis de qué país se trata tres dos uno
Exacto la República popular China
[Música]
[Aplausos]
os hemos hablado de ello en un pasado
vídeo aquí en visualpolitik y ahora si
algo ha quedado claro los últimos
tiempos es que depender demasiado de un
país para el suministro de un recurso
clave puede tener consecuencias nefastas
y si no pensad en el gas ruso más aún si
sepáis es una dictadura y un régimen
cada vez más hostil con occidente tal y
como ocurre con la china de silvin y
Compañía Así que poca broma Suecia puede
ser una vía de escape para evitar que el
viejo continente le pasen cosas como
estas 22 de septiembre de 2010 en medio
de las tensiones china bloquea
exportaciones vitales a Japón los
funcionarios de aduanas chinos están
deteniendo los envíos a Japón de las
llamadas tierras raras evitando que se
carguen a bordo de los barcos en los
puertos chinos 29 de mayo de 2019 China
está lista para usar las tierras raras
para contraatacar en la guerra comercial
con Estados Unidos avisaron periódicos
chinos el miércoles como para confiar en
los suministros de China por mucho que
este país tenga aproximadamente la de
todas las reservas probadas en el mundo
de tierras raras ojo con eso
y claro el problema es que según las
estimaciones de la propia Unión Europea
para el año 2030 la demanda de tierras
raras se va a multiplicar al menos por
cinco a nivel mundial coches eléctricos
Smartphone tablet redes tecnológicas
aerogeneradores la demanda va a ser
brutal y hablamos de menos de 7 años Así
que si no queremos que sien tenga la
sartén por el mango Pues hacen falta
alternativas y justo Ahí es donde entran
juego precisamente Suecia y también
otros países como Finlandia Claro está
desde luego los burócratas de Bruselas
parece que se están empezando a
preocupar por toda esta cuestión fijaos
la Unión Europea presentará objetivos
para la autosuficiencia de materias
primas en su ley de materias primas
críticas la comisión mirará Más allá de
las tierras raras clásicas del tipo del
escandio para centrarse también en otros
metales que se necesitan para la
transición ecológica dijo handley y
claramente el cobre será necesario para
la electrificación de la economía global
Claro que no penséis que esto genera
precisamente mucha tranquilidad en el
sector minero le tienen auténtico pavor
al apetito por La regulación de Bruselas
no me cre pues ellos mismos en este
momento es una prioridad aumentar La
regulación No creo que la prioridad es
tener proyectos exitosos entregando lo
que necesitas Con urgencia Mark
rakovides presidente del grupo de
presión euromimes sobre la futura ley de
materias primas críticas sea como sea
todo apunta que Suecia vivirá un Renacer
minero en los próximos años y que eso
puede ser una gran noticia para toda
Europa claro que para que eso ocurra
tenemos que cerrar el Triángulo Y es que
veréis hasta ahora tenemos ya dos lados
los recursos disponibles y las empresas
mineras que están deseando extraerlos
pero no nos falta el tercero estocolmo
Y es que veréis Durante los últimos años
el gobierno socialdemócrata de Suecia
pues no fue particularmente amigable con
esta industria los procesos burocráticos
por ejemplo se alargaron y las licencias
de exploración y explotación pues
sufrieron enormes retrasos de hecho
según la clasificación Internacional del
Freezer institute de Canadá entre los
años 2016 y 2021 Suecia ha pasado del
octavo puesto al número 36 en cuanto a
su atractivo para las inversiones
mineras Claro que hubo un momento porque
como muchos sabréis os hemos hablado de
ello en nuestro boletín de patreon en
octubre del 2022 se produjo un cambio de
color político en este país y ahora el
nuevo Primer Ministro sueco el
conservador ulf christerson ha sido
claro y cristalino con esta cuestión su
posición pues qué quiere que Suecia se
convierta de nuevo en una nación minera
Así que ahora este nuevo gobierno parece
querer facilitar que las empresas
mineras pues cojan el pico y la pala y
se pongan a trabajar a destajo incluso
quieren potenciar las inversiones de la
empresa pública de minería el caf que es
la mayor productora de hierro de todo el
continente y por cierto ahora que
hablamos de Suecia el nuevo gobierno
tiene la manga que seguro no os va a
dejar indiferentes Ni más ni menos
quieren reforzar su papel y convertirse
en una especie de potencia nuclear de
uso civil Claro está madre mía a greta
le debe estar dando un parque de tanto
disgusto atentos
la Suecia 3.0
Suecia uno de los países ecologistas
pronta podría convertirse en una de las
grandes potencias nucleares europeas
hablamos de energía nuclear civil Claro
está colmo todavía no se han planteado
que nosotros sepamos lo de las armas
nucleares pero lo de la energía de los
átomos como una de las claves del futuro
sí que está ya sobre la mesa y amigos
amigas parece que van muy pero que muy
en serio de hecho la clave del nuevo
gobierno sería la de sustituir el
concepto 100% energías renovables por el
de 100% energías libres de fósiles lo
que significa la entrada de la ecuación
de la producción nuclear Y la verdad es
que si lo pensamos pues tiene todo el
sentido
[Música]
La Apuesta sueca pasará concretamente
por los smr los pequeños reactores
modulares para ello están dispuestos a
modificar la legislación actual y dar
garantías de crédito públicas que hasta
ahora sólo estaban disponibles para las
energías renovables y no solo eso
incluso quieren prohibir por ley que un
nuevo gobierno intente agilizar la
clausura de reactores nucleares
arbitrariamente es decir quieren blindar
las inversiones En este tipo de energía
de hecho todo esto se ha plasmado en un
acuerdo el acuerdo de tido un acuerdo
que permitió formar gobierno y que se
alcanzó entre los partidos del bloque de
las derechas esto es los demócratas
cristianos los liberales los moderados y
los demócratas de Suecia
tal cual como lo escucháis un acuerdo
político Entre cuatro partidos que
apuntala la energía nuclear y no
olvidéis que estamos hablando de Suecia
es un giro de 180 grados y aún más este
acuerdo también contiene un compromiso
para desarrollar la legislación que sea
necesaria para implantar pequeños
reactores modulares en el país reactores
que se consideran el futuro de la
energía nuclear civil
[Música]
para ello se prevé acabar con el límite
que impone la ley sueca de un máximo de
10 reactores nucleares operando al mismo
tiempo se permitirá construir en nuevas
localizaciones diferentes a las de las
actuales plantas y se simplificará el
proceso de permisos para que os hagáis
una idea de lo que esto significa si
actualmente Suecia cuenta con seis
reactores que le proporcionan alrededor
del 31% de la energía el pedazo nuclear
del mix energético del futuro en Suecia
podría ser cercano al 50%
esto significa Ni más ni menos que la
energía nuclear podría convertirse en la
energía base en el país escandinavo con
las renovables que no son regulares como
apoyo para los picos de demanda
[Música]
Pues bien por el momento dos empresas ya
tienen firmado un memorándum para
planear el despliegue del futuro reactor
modular japonés el bw-rx-300 de la
General Electric Hitachi algo que
pondría Suecia La Vanguardia de las
nuevas energías a nivel europeo los smr
pueden proporcionar tanto a la industria
como a los municipios electricidad calor
e hidrógeno predecibles y libres de
combustibles fósiles junto con la nueva
energía eólica la nueva energía nuclear
será una pieza crucial del rompecabezas
de la transición climática laurentles
jefe del estudio de viabilidad de Nueva
construcción de fortune en fin ya lo
veis los ojos quieren volver a jugar la
gran pregunta o mejor dicho las dos
grandes preguntas son lo conseguirán les
dejarán hacerlo Pues bien por el momento
lo único que sabemos es que el estudio
para construir pequeños reactores
modulares en Suecia se complementará a
finales de 2023 o a principios de 2024
como siempre estaremos muy pero que muy
atentos a todo lo que pasa en el país
escandinavo pero mientras tanto las
preguntas son para ti logrará Suecia
convertirse en el país clave para la
transición energética en Europa gracias
a su poderosa industria minera podrás
llevar a cabo sus ambiciosos planes
nucleares en el largo plazo déjanos tus
respuestas por aquí abajo en los
comentarios y recuerda que si este vídeo
te ha gustado No olvides dar a like y
suscribirte al visualpolitik si es que
aún no lo has hecho Ah y si os gusta
visualpolitik y queréis recibir más no
olvidéis formar parte de la comunidad de
patreon os dejamos un enlace en la
descripción una vez más Muchas gracias
por estar ahí un saludo y hasta la
próxima
[Música]